so wir können jetzt so eine rubrik die
ist bisher noch unbekannt wird aber
bestimmt bald beliebt seien die haben
bestimmt oder stoß oder bin mal gespannt
was du
sagst mir jeden tag
also stimmt oder stolz drei thesen und
du sagst stimmt unterstützung
der nummer eins trotz fehlstart
innerhalb der nächsten fünf jahre wird
fredi bobic mit der meisterschale durchs
brandenburger tor fahren
warum ja das wird wenn wir irgendwas in
der hand mal haben sollten beide
behälter dann eher wahrscheinlich
richtung richtung pokal das wird das
wird eine schöne geschichte
die meisterschale glaube da bin ich zu
sehr realist gehört ich ich würde mich
aber auch nicht
wird bin ich verstecken was machen
müssten ja also als würde aber ich bin
realist verstoß walter
stoßen
auch wenn wir jetzt friedlich und der
härter gönnen und vielen anderen auch
natürlich die überlegenheit der bayern
möglicherweise leipzig weil sie auch
finanzielle möglichkeiten haben und
dauergast in der champions league sehen
friedens gerade ausgeführt
meine wette läuft ja vor zehn jahren
abgeschlossen dass der fc bayern zehn
mal hintereinander meister wird im
nächsten jahr wird so weit sein ich
werde diese wette gewinnen und sich in
diesem jahr
okay es geht um dich du hast uns geredet
und ich glaube eben das selbst so bald
wieder wird und auch in den nächsten
jahren und ich halte dagegen ich setze
auf dortmund auch wenn ich heute keine
guten argumente
wir sind immer zwei stimmt oder stoß
früher oder später holt fredi bobic sein
erfolgs trainer niko kovac zu hertha
müsste ich jetzt auch schluss sagen jaja
das war jetzt nicht so zu anfang wie es
ist ja nur ein paar vizes das kann nicht
von ihnen wissen was in zwei drei jahren
ist ja also es ist jetzt nicht also
jetzt würden wenn du mich jetzt sage ich
ja er ist sehr glücklich in monaco macht
einen tollen job da jaja da kämpft noch
um die champions league das er reinkommt
ich habe hier meine konzentration bei
der bei hertha bsc dass wir ein bisschen
da sind wir ein bisschen zu einfach dann
immer
und das weiß man auch nie also ganz
ehrlich ich hätte auch vom halben jahr
nicht gedacht um dreiviertel jahr nicht
gedacht dass ich das ich sind wir schon
ein bisschen weiter 34 jahr nicht
gedacht dass irgendwann hier in berlin
sitzt ich sage stimmt und ich und die
volksweise basieren
freddy und niko kovac so viel erfolg
miteinander hatten so gut
zusammengearbeitet haben und wenn sich
die gelegenheit ergibt und die
notwendigkeit da ist werden die beiden
sich wieder finden in die arme fallen ja
stimmt ja so ein bisschen stimmt
vielleicht oder stoß jetzt die dritte
stimmt oder stoß these die bundesliga
wird die 50 plus 1 regel kippen und
investoren die möglichkeit geben die
mehrheit des vereins zu übernehmen
das ist gut
das ist gut die frage oder die natürlich
die frage nein das ist ja jetzt höre
stimmt und stolz ist bis hin zu einfach
ja
das würde ich sagen weil es in den
nächsten größeren seite mittelfristig
nicht passieren wird weil wir ganz klar
zu 50 plus 1 bekennen stimmt würde ich
sagen dass es irgendwann nicht mehr
aufzuhalten sein wird ja weil ich
einfach auch da realist und deshalb
jetzt nichts mit der tat zu tun und mit
anderen vereinen oder wie auch immer die
für 50 prozent so wie wir alle stehen
werden wir wahrscheinlich irgendwann
nicht mehr darum herum kommen das würde
uns aufgezwungen werden ich glaube dass
es keine these sondern eine
notwendigkeit ist denn wir müssen uns
irgendwann mal entscheiden ob wir außer
bayern international noch mithalten
können dafür brauchen die klubs geld und
wir stellen ja auch fest dass die
traditionsvereine wie
man schalke 04 ein eingetragener verein
natürlich ohne investoren auf dauer
nicht mehr mithalten können natürlich
gibt es da auch manager fehler und die
falschen strukturen aber ich glaube dass
vereine wie schalke werder bremen der
hamburger sv die wir alle so vermissen
in der bundesliga erst wieder eine
chance haben mitzuspielen mit 50 plus 1
feld und investoren
daneben dafür sorgen dass es auch wieder
bessere voraussetzungen aber du
persönlich bisher nichts befürworter von
50 plus eins du möchtest jetzt lars
winter es nicht als alleinigen nein ich
finde ich habe meine persönliche meinung
und unabhängig von den klubs ja ja wo
ich jetzt auch gearbeitet haben haben
wir für vereine gaben die für höchste
plus 1 stehen ja und da bin ich
natürlich auch konform und habe auch
kein problem damit noch mal ja aber
trotzdem die tradition und das hatte
friedrich gesagt
verhindert oft dieses moderne nach vorne
denken ja ja die tradition ist etwas
schönes ist ein gut ja dass man dass man
wirklich wahren muss und nur auch für
die für die zukunft aber trotzdem muss
man sich neu aufstellen und ich finde
dass traditionsvereine oft daran
scheitern an diesen strukturen die sie
haben wenn sie sie nicht von innen
heraus verändern wollen sie können das
schaffen wir haben das in frankfurt auch
gesehen man kann das schaffen ja aber da
mussten wir müssen alle mitmachen und
das werden wir genauso hier zum beispiel
bei der hertha versuchen auch aber meine
ganz persönliche meinung ist dass es
notwendig ist dass das jeder eigentlich
das recht hat seine unternehmensstruktur
das ist ja jetzt blöd an meinem fußball
aber es ist ebenso so so zu gestalten
wie er es möchte ja also das würde
bedeuten bedeuten für uns eins darf in
der hinsicht keine rolle spielen ja weil
jemand wird nur investieren wenn er eine
eine gescheite und gesunde struktur
vorfinden